PLANESNOW, ONWIDE.
FAA INVESTIGATORS WANT TMAKEHE
ALASKA AIRLIPL E
>> ATIF THANE'
FUSELAGE BLEW OFS AFTER
TAKEOFF, SUCKING SOM
BE
NOBODY W
THE NTSB ADMITTED ERT THEYT LUC.
JOINI
FROM PORTLAND,
WHAT ARE W AS INVEST
>> V O
IMPORTANNDINKING OF THNTSBSTRES
THE INVESTIGATIOEY NOT,
I REPEAT, NOT COER THE
OVERALL DESIGNF THE WI
ATRGAX FLEET.
PL ANT, OKING SPECIFICALLY THIS
LARGE PIECE OF THE
PLAN TR PLUG, S L MISSING,ICD A,
S EARLY NING
HOUR.
NARWED THSEARCHN,COIR LAST NIG.
E Y HILLS, WE'RE
C
FOREST.E
OF HOMES.LOSTONS OF SUIV, HUNDRS
THL WE'RR  TO
LOOK FOR FBID
PERSONNEL GOIN
H PEOP BAC
ISE KE
E  THE PLANETHNTSB C
MADE IT A
ICATION POINT TO SAY HOW
LUCKBOARD WERE
ABOUT SAFETYD ABOULISTT FRONT. R
WE HAVE THE SAFEST AVIATION
WE ARE T STANDAR
AROUND THE WORLD, BUT
WE HAVAT DARD.
SO
HA IN THE
HOURS, THE FT
BE SEN PORTLAND TO NTSB
HEADQUARTERS IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
EER
NTING UN
STINOUAUTHORITIES TO IASH IN
S ARE UTTERL
WORKS ON ADDS TOERSPECTI A ACRO
STATESE WORLE
D TOSE
XALY VALERIO, THANK YOU VE
LET'S BRING IN FORME
VE.
SAFET                        SA
OF THESE MAX 9 TY
REPLACOORS OR
DEVADOT T E PLANES ARELY
VERYHEY'REO
I NTSB OR
ED THIS
PLE D A
PRESSURIZA PY KS OTIME OCI THATH
DOORWAS OF
PRESSURIZATION PROBLEM, BUT
THEY'LT .
'L LOOKING AT THE
MECHANICS THAT MUST
THAT DOOR.
HESI
YOU CAN'OPEN I
BUT DID THEY CLOSE IT PROPERLY?
AS MIKE POINTED OUT, THEY'RE
OBVIOUSLY GOINING
FOR E MIG
SOMEBODY'S
NTSB CHAHE CASE TO T
THE PUICN THLOOKOUT
LET'S U D
MANUFACTURY A SUBCONTRACTOR
S.
HTS LAE
G MANUFAEDE MAPANYLLIRITD TO O,
GUESS FOR ECONOMIC REANS
SURELY THOSE -
A F
SERES ANY.
THEY MUST HA WRITTEN THE
L STRDH
HAD TOY THE
HE 737.P IN MIND THESEPLUG DOOR
UNY'N OU
E .
YOU HAVE A LEA  OA PIECE
OF EQUIPMEAN
MAINTENANCEISRERT BE LOOK THE
HISTORY OF THESEG
ALSO.
>>EF
ASE HISTORY OF THEANES CONSIDERA
THEY'VE BEEN INVVE DEADL
CRASHES, AND OF COURSE I
YS T WE
ISSUE THESE37NS.BROADEFOEI
PLANES, SPECAL THEAX? W BOEIN
HISTORY OF ENGINEENG
OTHER Y OR ATTUNEDNT
AIRBUS.NOW AIS DOING
IS
SCIENT A IONED, A AS AN N THE F